you get much more value for your money
here you hardly pay anything and you get
an education that is I would say on the
same level if not better than many
American universities
I really wasn't sure what to expect
coming here I had heard that it could be
harder some people think that European
universities will be much harder
I really like the flexibility of being
able to not go to a class if I don't
feel that I'm going to get anything from
it and to be able to study the material
in a way that I find beneficial but at
the same time not knowing what's
expected of me always is difficult
professors here expect you to study a
lot more on your own
I think I'm I'm getting a good education
here and one that is recognized around
the world and in the u.s. in particular
I really like living in an environment
where I'm around other international
students and other Germans
young and broke you're not alone they
told us you work hard you get an
education and you'll get a good job but
they were wrong we're facing